interesting and unfortunate beginning to
a two nothing game late opposite rails
III now they've got a play on alive and
that's all he needed he was gone a
little fade away think Thompson he's
just a machine Magadan pumps it down
Livingston
can't play him any better beautifully
done he didn't just a couple times
[Applause]
finish thought he was fouled and he's
trying to get fouled again I'm trying to
accentuate that when he found play
instead
the point you mentioned in Cleveland
Kevin's passings underrated model 30
ticks at the first half there's a good
look play and it's a perfect gotta
bounce like as loony set a nice screen
and you're already calling it good
before he shot it
Thompson hides behind sighs I feel sad
three then we check in with careth Burke
from Arizona on the in son did try to
force it he got stopped and he just lost
it this could be a good sign in flavor
really starts to get rolling right now
I'd look for clay again he's training to
play at Staples there it is and
perfectly done perfectly in gym
Barnett's doing play before play even
shoot a free throw that quarter
[Music]
at home his normal mezcla thing could be
the protector this is a four shot but he
might get it cleaned up he's peeling it
ladies got 31 that will timeouts all the
time though you know on the road you're
not playing well the other teams gotta
give it to you a little bit
you got to play through it later
they don't they need a shot first not
eternal watch it and it's played down on
Lena sometimes he does that and it looks
so easy so natural